bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat vous le voyez ici salle des
conférences on se prépare pour les
traditionnelles questions d'actualité et
dernière de l'année 2013 et pour
commenter toute cette année pour faire
un petit peu de bilan et puis bien sûr
pour commenter l'actualité du jour je
reçois alain vidalis bonjour le ministre
en charge des du parlement les relations
avec le parlement la vie d'alice bonjour
beaucoup d'actualité évidemment on va
commencer si vous le voulez bien par la
centrafrique nous sommes engagés sur le
théâtre des opérations
le ministre de la défense a très
clairement précisé que nous serions là
certainement au bois pour six mois est
ce que cela veut dire que il y aura
prochainement une vote dans les deux
assemblées car la loi l'y oblige
finalement au bout de quatre mois il ya
forcément un débat et au vote mais vous
avez tout à fait raison le gouvernement
va naturellement respecter les
obligations prévues par l'article 35 de
la constitution qui interviennent à deux
moments d'abord une obligation
d'information dès le début des
opérations c'est ce qui a été fait cette
semaine avec le débat qui a eu lieu au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale et puis
la réception mardi matin par le premier
ministre de l'ensemble des responsables
majorité opposition des groupes
parlementaires ça c'est l'obligation
d'information et lorsque une
intervention extérieure dure plus de
quatre mois il faut un vote pour avoir
l'autorisation du parlement et
naturellement compte tenu des délais que
l'on peut envisager aujourd'hui de cette
intervention il faudra probablement qui
lié au bout de quatre mois un vote du
parlement la défense a bien précisé
c'est minimum 6 mois évidemment on peut
imaginer le temps de faire revenir les
hommes et le matériel natura ça pourrait
aussi que nous oui ça pourrait être
aussi plus longtemps même si je crois
que délais des précisions ont aidés ont
été donnés notamment au moment du sommet
de paris sur l'objectif l'objectif il
est bien à la fois une intervention
humanitaire une intervention de sécurité
et puis une transition démocratique et
n'est pas facile dans un pays où il faut
reconstituer les listes électorales les
l'état civil mais l'objectif d'essayer
de mener à bien l'ensemble de la
procédure sécurisation transition
démocratique avant la fin de l'année
2014 reste un objectif
même si d'autres dates ont été données
alors c'est vrai que nous sommes sur le
terrain nous sommes en guerre pour
autant loi de programmation militaire a
été votée ici même au sénat je voudrais
avoir votre avis et que vous puissiez
aussi nous éclairer le coût de ce qu'on
est en train d'intervenir en
centrafrique c'est quelque chose qui est
déjà programmée dans cette loi de
programmation militaire où c'est quelque
chose qui va coûter aux plus offrants
c'est parce que les gens ne savent pas
forcément les éclairer c'est déjà
quelque chose qui est programmé il ya
une provision pour les interventions
extérieures ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que y compris avec l'intervention en
centrafrique aujourd'hui il y aura moins
d'hommes à l'extérieur dans ces
opérations qui n'avaient en 2013 puisque
parallèlement il y à la fin du
désengagement en afghanistan la
diminution des effectifs des effectifs
au mali nous sommes toujours présents au
mali vous le confirme il ya un
désengagement une 1600 militaires
aujourd'hui en centrafrique dont un
certain nombre y était déjà auparavant
et les effectifs se sont en voie de
réduction sur le mali donc il n'y a pas
de problème sur le financement est
certainement aussi l'opposition qui dit
qu il y évidemment il soutient l'action
du gouvernement dans cette guerre mais
il a du mal à comprendre pourquoi nous
on est aussi seul pourquoi est-ce que
nous sommes isolés évidemment il ya
aussi une question sur le coût de cette
guerre oui il ya deux problèmes la ya le
problème du coach il faut quand même une
certaine
hypocrisie pour dire on est d'accord
pour y aller mais si ça coûtait rien
c'est pas possible si on y va on assume
le coût de financiers de l'opération
d'ailleurs il est déjà prévu et je pense
qu'en est-il combien non mais il n'ya
pas d'estimation qui sont faites
aujourd'hui on n'est pas là dans une
comptabilité s'cusez moi un peu
d'épicier en disant si ça coûte trop
tant pis que les gens meurent
franchement on y va c'est pas
insurmontable c'est déjà prévu dans le
budget de la france et je pense que ce
débat est aujourd'hui un débat qui n'est
pas à la hauteur du problème
deuxièmement il ya la question de vous
êtes seul ils ont aussi raison de poser
cette question là et c'est peut-être pas
faux non plus mais qui est juste mais
nous sommes les premiers à regretter que
les autres ne veulent pas venir avec
nous et notamment on peut à la fois
décidé qu on doit y aller parce que si
la france qui va pas personne n'y va et
que les gens continuent à se massacrer
qui marche c'est ça la question à
laquelle le président de la république a
dû répondre et il ya répondu avec la
seule réponse qui me paraît possible
aujourd'hui et en même temps regretté
justement que les autres n'est pas la
même exigence vis-à-vis de la défense
d'un certain nombre de droits universels
et de la protection des populations
quand je dis les autres c'est
naturellement l'europe oui notamment
l'europe et là vous voyez peut-être vous
visez peut-être un pays est ce que ça
veut dire aussi que la france est la
seule capable d'intervenir sur ce
terrain d'abord c'est vrai que la france
a des moyens militaires qu'elle a su
conserver parce que c'est une grande
puissance mais justement y compris sur
les questions financières y compris
lorsque on regarde les déficits de la
france il faudrait aussi que ceux qui ne
veulent pas bouger prennent aussi en
compte les efforts que la france fait
c'est a donc fait sur le plan financier
aussi sur le plan financier c'est pas
forcément la seule réponse pour
l'instant ça serait bien venu mais
surtout surtout je pense qu'il faudrait
que l'europe de la défense devienne une
réalité pas simplement un slogan de
discours vous attendez des bonnes
nouvelles du sommet européen qui doit se
tenir la semaine prochaine voilà il
paraît qu'avec la belgique il ya des
discussions qui sont plutôt positives
voilà c'est le sujet c'est les chefs
d'état c'est pas mon niveau de
compétence mais naturellement le
problème est posé par le président de la
république votre niveau de compétence et
peut-être aussi le parlement et surtout
le parlement je vous propose de passer
un petit peu au bilan de cette année
vous rappeler l'année dernière on avait
déjà discuté ensemble et on se disait
les parlementaires travaillent trop il
que légifère trop vite est ce que ça
change et ça
a pas changé dans la mesure où les
parlementaires sont les parlementaires
ont beaucoup légiférer qu'il y avait des
textes importants ce que je retiens
c'est qu'on nous annonçait une année
avec une énorme difficulté à venir était
le texte sur les retraites qui devait
embrasé la france ce gouvernement
réussit une réforme des retraites qui a
été voté par le parlement qui sera votée
définitivement le 18 décembre prochain à
l'assemblée nationale du moins je du
moins je l'espère une réforme juste qui
répondait vie site financier a en même
temps qu'il prend en compte pour la
première fois la pénibilité tous ces
rendez vous ont été des rendez-vous
réussi pour la majorité le gouvernement
sans faire de la comptabilité d'épicier
je reprends un petit peu vos thèmes de
tout à l'heure combien texte
aujourd'hui c'est pas fini la session
la plupart des textes seront adoptées
d'ici à la fin de la semaine ils sont
remettre autour d'une quarantaine de
textes mais le la hiérarchie est pas la
même il ya deux siècles évidemment
extrêmement important la finance la loi
de finances le financement de la
sécurité sociale
et puis la loi sur sur les retraites les
lois sur les transparences pas toute une
série de lois qui marqueront je pense
l'histoire de la de la république n'est
quand même une quinzaine de textes qui
ont été soumis au conseil
constitutionnel qui ont été aussi qui
ont fait l'objet d'un validation oui est
ce que c'est parce que ça va trop vite
parce que c'est mal écrit pourquoi
est-ce que ce soit validé ces textes ils
sont invalidés pas plus qu'avant le
nombre de recours n'est pas supérieur à
ce qui existait précédemment et c'est un
vrai contrôle qui est exercée qui est
normal par le conseil constitutionnel
souvent il s'agit de censure sur la
réécriture du texte et il n'y a pas de
censure en nombre de censure qui
révèlerait tout d'un coup qu'il ya une
accélération de la mauvaise qualité de
la loi on est absolument dans les
interventions habituelles du conseil
constitutionnel habituel est souhaitable
parce que c'est vrai que le conseil à
l'issue du travail parlementaire censure
ce qui n'est pas toujours
l'initiative du gouvernement ce qui est
aussi parfois le résultat de ce que le
débat
est là le fardeau est partagée de ce
point de vue là y'a des censures du
conseil constitutionnel qui concernent
souvent des textes qui ont été ajoutées
tout simplement parce qu'on considère
que c'est des cavaliers c'est à dire
qu'il n'était pas il n'avait pas un lien
suffisamment fort avec le texte
d'origine à vous poser plusieurs
questions sur 2013 évidemment mais si
vous aviez un exemple pour revenir en
arrière sur un texte cette année
emblématique sur lequel vous
souhaiteriez revenir au derrière
peut-être qu'il s'est bien passé mal
passé ça serait lequel non je pense que
nous avons un c'est difficile mais je
pense que le texte important pour les
français pour la vie quotidienne peu
compte tenu de ce qu était l'ambition de
ce texte sera le texte sur les retraites
mais les textes qui resteront peut-être
qu'ils marqueront pour longtemps notre
vie collective y aura le texte sur la
transparence que j'ai porté là c'est
vrai un peu pro domo mais il ya aussi un
texte qui n'a pas eu de tout le succès
voulu au sénat mais sur le cumul des
mandats qui n'est pas terminé mais qui
s'achèvera au mois deux mois de janvier
pour cause parce qu'il crée beaucoup de
tumulte cette région il craint d écrire
le débat on le connaît bien mais ce sont
des textes qui ont été voulus par le
gouvernement et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment avec le texte sur le mariage
pour tous ce sont des textes d'une
importance sur ce texte sur lequel sur
le broyage pour tous sur la façon dont
ça s'est passé sur le débat a été un
grand débat franchement ça a été un
grand débat avec des affrontements il ya
eu des moments de tension ce qui s'est
passé au parlement parfois un peu dérapé
mais ça a été un débat de qualité je
dirais pas la même chose de ce qui s'est
passé dans la rue alain vidalies je sais
que vous devez regagné l'hémicycle en
deux mots la personnalité de l'année
peut-être politique ou autre l'événement
de l'année pour vous
l'événement de l'année je pense que
c'est l'adoption du texte du sur l'eau
pour le mariage pour tous je pense que
c'était une aspiration depuis longtemps
et que ça marquera l'année et puis la
personnalité
de l'année bien disons celle qui a porté
le texte et christiane taubira merci
beaucoup à la vie d'alice on vous laisse
regagné l'hémicycle les questions
d'actualité vont bientôt commencer au
programme des questions complètement
différente d'une part sur l'ukraine avec
le face à face qui a lieu en ce moment
dans la rue à kiev notamment une
question sur le jour de carence des
fonctionnaires qui a été supprimée qui a
été remis par marylise lebranchu les
négociations notamment sur les
travailleurs détachés dont on a beaucoup
parlé en début de semaine et puis sur la
situation fiscale question qui sera
adressée de marie hélène des esgaulx du
groupe ump jean marc ayrault mais jean
marc ayrault n'est pas là c'est pierre
moscovici qui répondra à sa place on va
bientôt rejoindre l'hémicycle politiques
traditionnelles questions d'actualité
qui sont présidée aujourd'hui par jean
pierre bel et puis nous reviendrons dans
un second temps à partir de 16h pour on
refait la séance on parlera de plusieurs
propositions de loi qui seront débattus
au sénat cet après midi la première sur
les jours du voyage un thème très
important pour les mères il ya de
nombreux sénateurs maires ici présents
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle et puis sur
la loi sur le handicap une proposition
de loi du sénateur
vice-président du sénat didier guillaume
qui viendra nous en parler sur ce
plateau et puis nous parlerons également
de la centrafrique avec gérard longuet
l'ancien ministre défense qui viendra
nous donner son point de vue sur ce qui
est en train de se passer en
centrafrique en ce moment où les
militaires français sont engagés sur le
terrain de la centrafrique va tout de
suite si la séance des questions
d'actualité à commencer en maudit qui a
encore un petit peu d'attentes mais très
peu en tout cas jean pierre bel a pris
place dans l'hémicycle etc nous allons
tout de suite écouter cette séance des
questions d'actualité à tout à l'heure
encore quelques secondes de patience
jean pierre bel ne serait tarder à dire
que la séance des questions d'actualité
est ouverte et voilà à tout à l'heure la
séance s'est reprise mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que pour l'auteur de la
question et le ministre ou la ministre
pour sa réponse 2 minutes 30
la parole est à madame cécile de
kupperman pour le groupe src
tuer le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues dans tous les pays
on célèbre à juste raison est quasi
unanimement la disparition de nelson
mandela qui a longtemps été considéré
comme le plus vieux prisonnier politique
du monde cette ferveur et ce respect par
est aujourd'hui naturel cet homme que
beaucoup en temps qualifié de terroriste
a toujours lutté pour le droit à la
résistance contre toute forme
d'oppression il su réussir la
réconciliation de tous les sud africains
après la libération de ce peuple en ce
début de 21e siècle il y encore de par
le monde des femmes et des hommes qui
sont emprisonnés pour les idées qu'ils
défendent je pense en particulier à
marwan barghouti résistants palestiniens
qui symbolise aujourd'hui la lutte de
tout un peuple contre 46 ans
d'occupation israélienne de la
cisjordanie et de la bande de gaza après
avoir longtemps partager l'espoir né du
processus de négociations de paix d'oslo
il a été emprisonné pour sa
participation aux deux révoltes
populaires qui ont suivi la poursuite de
la colonisation de l'oppression et le
reniement des engagements des
gouvernements israël
marwan barghouti comme des milliers
d'autres militants palestiniens et
détenu pour avoir lutté pour le droit
inaliénable de son peuple à se libérer
de l'oppression
méfions-nous que les terroristes d'hier
ne soient les héros de la liberté de
demain au moment où les autorités
israéliennes parle à nouveau avec force
de négociations de paix sa libération et
celle de ses camarades serait un gage de
sincérité et de bonne volonté
c'est un défi qu'il faut lancer avec
toutes les femmes et tous les hommes
épris de justice et de paix de par le
monde
permettez-moi une citation dans le monde
entier des femmes et des hommes sont
encore en prison du fait de ce qu'ils
sont du fait de ce qu'ils disent la
lutte doit continuer nelson mandela
aurait pu prononcer ces mots mais c'est
barack obama qui les a prononcés mardi
dernier à johannesburg
ma question sera donc direct monsieurzen
ministre quelles initiatives
la france est-elle décidé à prendre en
son nom propre ou auprès des instances
internationales pour obtenir la
libération de marwan barghouti et des
prisonniers politiques
merci la parole est à monsieur thierry
repentin pardon ministre chargé des
affaires européennes on a même la
sénatrice faut trop question est fondé à
double titre sur le fond est aussi une
question d'actualité au moment où le
quai d'orsay ce matin remettait à
plusieurs ong oeuvrant à l'égard de
personnes privées de liberté sur la
planète des prix pour accompagner leurs
efforts au cours de l'année 2014 mais
plus précisément concernant la situation
de monsieur marwan barghouti je souhaite
vous confirmer que les autorités
françaises suivent avec une très grande
attention le cas de marouane barghouti
un effet elles sont conscientes du
symbole que monsieur marc booty
représente au sein de la classe
politique palestinienne et du crédit
qu'il conserve auprès de l'opinion
publique ce dernier pourrait en effet le
moment venu jouer un rôle important une
contribution utile aux efforts de paix
conduits par le président abbas nous
maintenons d'ailleurs des contacts
réguliers avec son épouse madame
barghouti que le ministre des affaires
étrangères laurent fabius a rencontré en
mars dernier d'une manière générale la
france suit attentivement la situation
de l'ensemble des prisonniers politiques
palestiniens à titre national comme avec
ses partenaires européens et l'a à
plusieurs reprises appelé les autorités
israéliennes au respect de leurs
obligations à l'égard de ces deux tenues
notamment dans le domaine du droit
international des droits de l'homme et
du droit international humanitaire la
france appelle aussi les israéliens les
palestiniens à effectuer des gestes
significatifs
susceptibles de développer la confiance
dans le cadre des négociations de paix
en cours elle estime qu'à la libération
de prisonniers par les autorités
israéliennes constitue une contribution
utile en ce sens s'agissant de la
recherche d'un règlement politique la
france est constamment mobilisée pour
faire avancer la cause de la paix la
visite du président de la république
française en israël et dans les
territoires palestiniens les 17 et 18
novembre dernier a permis de marquer le
plein soutien de la france aux
négociations en cours est de réitérer
les positions et les attentes françaises
le président de la république a
fermement souligné
l'urgence de parvenir à un accord
définitif
renouvelé le soutien de la france à la
solution de deux états pour les deux
peuples il a engagé les deux parties à
faire les gestes nécessaires pour faire
progresser les négociations et à cet
égard il a salué la libération de
prisonniers par les autorités
israéliennes en marquant que cette
mesure n'était qu'une étape dans le
processus qui exigeait des gestes de
part et d'autre merci merci la parole au
président jacques mézard pour le groupe
rdse
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
elle est relative aux institutions de la
république et au rôle du sénat
pour nous il est inopportun de modifier
ces institutions sans recourir à un
processus de révision constitutionnelle
or nous craignons que cela pourrait être
votre objectif et vous le savez notre
groupe est profondément attaché aux
bicamérisme et en conséquence au respect
de la place et du rôle du sénat dans nos
institutions
un sénat disposant de ses pouvoirs
législatifs dans tous les domaines mais
avec sa spécificité
l'impossibilité de renverser le
gouvernement et aussi ses missions
particulières concernant les
collectivités territoriales mission
reconnue très clairement par la
constitution
à ce sujet nous avons relevé avec une
certaine inquiétude pour ne point dire
davantage les propos de monsieur olivier
dussopt député
rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale du
projet de loi décentralisation métropole
en ce moment en discussion
lequel répondant à la question
allez-vous réintroduire le haut conseil
des territoires a répondu c'est dans la
gazette des communes gelé là
je le cite le gouvernement y est
extrêmement favorable
les sénateurs parle d'un sénat bis il
n'intègre pas la perspective du
non-cumul
mais le jour où le non cumul sera
appliquée il faudra un lieu de
concertation entre le gouvernement et
les responsables des principaux
exécutifs locaux ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est monsieur du soap qui dit que
c'est la volonté du gouvernement et que
ça remplacera le rôle du sénat par
rapport aux collectivités on ne saurait
être plus clair et le débat d'hier à
l'assemblée nationale ne nous à points
rassurée le haut conseil des territoires
pendant du projet de loi non cumul c'est
le déclin assuré
si ce n'est pas la fin du sénat ce haut
conseil je le dis n'était pas une
proposition des associations d'élus
comme on nous le fait croire aujourd'hui
il leur a été un style et au fil des
négociations car ce haut conseil c'est
la proposition numéro un du rapport
terra nova de 2011 avec le binôme et le
non cumul la question est simple
monsieur le premier ministre
quel et quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement sur le projet de au conseil
des territoires et plus généralement sur
l'avenir du sénat de la république
merci la parole est à monsieur alain
vidalis ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement merci merci monsieur
le président monsieur le président
mézard
l'article 24 de la constitution que vous
connaissez parfaitement
précise que le parlement vote la loi
qu'ils contrôlent l'action du
gouvernement qu'il évalue les politiques
publiques et surtout qu'il comprend
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat et que
le sénat sur la représentativité des
collectivités territoriales de la
république le gouvernement n'a aucune
intention de modifier l'article 24 de la
constitution
au contraire le gouvernement entend
réaffirmer son attachement au
bicamérisme qui est indispensable à la
qualité de la loi et à l'effectivité du
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
le sénat est aujourd'hui au rendez-vous
de cette exigence et le gouvernement je
veux le rappeler a choisi l'examen en
premier par le sénat ce qui est une
marque de confiance d'un texte par
exemple aussi important que la loi de
programmation militaire que votre
assemblée a adopté définitivement mardi
lundi votre assemblée a adopté la loi
d'habilitation pour la simplification de
la vie des entreprises et il est
vraisemblable que l'assemblée nationale
votera conforme le texte venant du sénat
hier le sénat conforme à sa tradition a
voté un texte important pratiquement à
l'unanimité me semble-t-il dont vous
étiez le rapporteur sur la création de
l'asem à objets uniques tous la marque
aujourd'hui que contrairement à certains
commentateurs il y as au sénat même si
dans certaines circonstances la réalité
politique fait qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de majorité mais pourquoi le reste le
sénat est présent et amène sa pierre son
travail à l'oeuvre législatives alors
vous l'interrogez particulièrement à la
fois sur les projets du gouvernement par
rapport au sénat je crois que je viens
de rappeler cet engagement il est très
fort et nous avons eu ce débat sur
d'autres textes monsieur le président et
vous le savez nous sommes partisans de
reconnaître la spécificité du sénat mais
pas sa spécialité comme cela aurait pu
être l'une des conséquences que sur ce
qui fait notre divergences notamment sur
la question du cumul des mandats au fond
il y à des pays où la deuxième chambre à
une spécialité mais ces pays sont des
pays acp organisations fédérales est la
seule façon pour la france d'être à la
fois une république et une république
qui respecte le sénat c'est bien d'avoir
deux chambres et un bicamérisme avec
deux chambres qui sont reconnus chacune
à égalité de pouvoir comme dans
l'article 24 c'est la vision que nous
avons du bicaméralisme je tiens à le
renforcer renforcé aujourd'hui cette
déclaration au nom du gouvernement et
s'agissant d'un texte qui est en débat
le gouvernement s'exprimait monsieur le
président sur ce conseil mais il y à une
procédure parlementaire le débat est en
cours à l'assemblée nationale il y aura
une cmp et si la cmp abouti le
gouvernement sera évidemment très
attentifs aux résultats de la cmp
s'enferre d'à priori car son objectif
évidemment c'est de respecter le sénat
de respecter la procédure parlementaire
notamment sur ce grand texte qui sera la
réforme des métropoles persie très bien
merci la parole est un jeu à longué pour
le groupe ump
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur laurent fabius entre milices
des affaires étrangères qui est absent à
cet instant je suis persuadé que nous
aurons une réponse
l'opposition en général et l'ump en
particulier
lorsque la france est engagée à
l'étranger
s'efforce de soutenir son autorité
et considère que les divisions
partisanes légitime d'ailleurs
ne doivent en aucun cas l'emporter c'est
une attitude dont nous ne nous
débarquerons pas pourquoi nous avons
soutenu l'intervention au mali
nous soutenons à cet instant
l'intervention rca
et au nom de l'autorité de la france
nous avions émis des doutes sur les
déclarations du président la république
concernant la syrie je dois constater
que ces doutes étaient fondés il l'a
lui-même constaté d'ailleurs peu après
ma question concerne l'ukraine
nous souhaitons non pas faire le procès
de ce pays qui est connu et hélas connu
par ses excès et par ses échecs
mais nous voudrions connaître l'attitude
du président de la république et celle
du gouvernement au regard d'une crise
qui concerne toute l'europe et qui
concerne les relations de l'europe avec
ce grand voisin
qui a été à la fois à notre grand allié
et parfois notre grande menace lorsque
c'était l'union soviétique je parle de
la russie
il ya manifestement dans la crise
ukrainienne un choix
qu'elle est la volonté du gouvernement
français que les la volonté du président
de la république de peser dans cette
crise et en particulier
et ma question s'articule autour de
trois demandes
aurons-nous la clarté de madame merkel
et de sa majorité
pour manifester aux côtés des partisans
de l'europe
nous nous contenterons nous d'inviter
monsieur vitali klitschko à venir
déjeuner à paris ce qui d'ailleurs un
geste élégant mais insuffisant la
deuxième question a trait à la demande
même présenté par le gouvernement de
kiev lors du sommet de vilnius le 29
novembre dernier s'agit-il pour vous
d'un chantage absolue cherchant la
rupture ou d'une demande d'un pays en
désarroi et la troisième et dernière
question au fond quelle est votre
politique vis-à-vis de la russie nous
allons célébrer le centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale l'année
prochaine
l'alliance franco russe est un facteur
de solidité en europe nous aimerions
connaître quel jugement la france porte
sur le droit de la russie de s'organiser
à côté de l'europe et peut-elle
s'organiser avec leurs hommes en évitant
tout conflit inutile merci monsieur
thierry aux planteurs
c'est le sénateur langage vous remercie
de votre question qui me permet aussi de
revenir sur un déplacement que j'ai
effectué le 5 décembre donc il ya
quelques jours à kiev où je me suis
rendu sur la place de l'indépendance
pour discuter avec les manifestants
avant de rencontrer d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des représentants de
l'opposition ainsi que la famille de
madame timochenko
les manifestations qui ont lieu
quotidiennement à kiev depuis plus d'une
dizaine de jours appels de la france
trois mots d'ordre je veux être précis
le premier mot d'ordre c'est l'appel à
la non violence plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes manifestent jour
et nuit effectivement dans la capitale
ukrainienne dans un climat de tension
qui a fait de nombreux blessés
y compris d'ailleurs chez les
journalistes qui couvrent cette
événement les forces de l'ordre ont dans
les derniers jours tentes et des
opérations d'évacuation même si la nuit
dernière a été effectivement plus calme
ceci étant la france appelle au respect
du droit de manifester et à la plus
grande retenue nous ne le disons aux
autorités gouvernementales
rien ne sera possible
si la paix civile n'est pas assuré les
revendications qu'ils s'expriment sont
pacifiques j'en ai été témoin elles
doivent donc être traitées pacifiquement
le deuxième mot d'ordre c'est celui de
la reprise de dialogue d'un côté le
président ianoukovitch accepte le
principe d'une conciliation et de
l'autre il déploie des forces de l'ordre
dans le centre ville refuse de dialoguer
avec l'opposition
il faut c'est nécessaire je pense que
nous pouvons être tous d'accord que le
dialogue soit renoué entre le
gouvernement et les oppositions qui sont
dans la rue c'est l'objet de l'e change
d'ailleurs qui a eu lieu hier entre
laurent fabius et monsieur klitschko
lequel doit être aussi respectés et
écoutés comme porte parole des
revendications du peuple ukrainien et le
troisième mot d'ordre c'est la volonté
d'ouverture de l'union européenne vers
l'ukraine qui reste totalement intacte
nous demeurons favorables à l'accord
d'association avec l'ukraine le
président de la république lui même l'a
dit à vilnius à l'occasion du sommet du
partenariat oriental
mais l'europe ce n'est pas qu'une
affaire de marchands de tapis par
rapport à ce que pourrait offrir ou non
telle ou telle autre puissance l'ukraine
n'est pas acheter comme l'europe n'est
pas à vendre je veux d'ailleurs souligné
qu'à nos yeux il n'ya pas d'antagonisme
entre la signature d'un accord
d'association avec l'europe est le fait
d'être proche de la russie c'est un
message que nous à vont passer à la
partie ukrainienne
c'est la mission qui était devenu à
madame ashton au lond union européenne
non-violence dialogue maintien de
l'ouverture européenne c'est ça notre
position et c'est au peuple ukrainien
dont le droit de manifester doit être
pleinement respectée de lire
pacifiquement quelle est la sienne merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est un
autre collègue vincent capo-canellas
pour le groupe udi uc
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
marylise lebranchu ministre de la
fonction publique madame la ministre
vous avez annoncé il ya quelques mois la
suppression de la journée de carence
pour les arrêts maladie des
fonctionnaires
motif alors invoqué
l'inutilité supposée de la mesure
pourtant une étude récemment publiée
rappelle que depuis l'instauration de
cette journée de carence
les arrêts maladie courts ont
drastiquement chuté
les chiffres sont éloquents en 2012 le
nombre d'absences d'une journée a reculé
de 41% dans les hôpitaux et de 43% dans
les collectivités territoriales
si les données équivalentes font défaut
dans la fonction publique d'état force
est de constater que la journée de
carence n'a rien d'inutile c'est
justement le moment que vous choisissez
pour paradoxalement la supprimer
l'expérimentation menée deux ans durant
avec sus et ne sera donc pas pérenniser
alors même qu'elles rentrent montrent
des résultats positifs ce qui n'a vous
en conviendrez pas grand sens sa
suppression aura un impact négatif pour
les finances publiques puisque elle
coûtera au minimum 150 7 millions
d'euros l'année prochaine et qu'elle
désorganisera les services notamment
dans l'hôpital public où le jour de
carence avait permis de faire des
économies c'est un très mauvais signal
au moment où les efforts de maîtrise de
la dépense publique doivent être accrus
validé par les faits la journée de
carence justifie aussi sur le plan des
principes je rappelle que dans le
secteur privé le délai de carence et
deux trois jours c'est donc une mesure
d'équité et dans cette période où l'on
demande des efforts aux français il
n'est pas inutile de rappeler que
l'effort n'est juste que s'il est
partagé alors pourquoi la supprimer
d'aucuns avancent l'argument des arrêts
de maladie longs mais il n'y a
évidemment aucun lien entre les deux on
ne remplace pas un jour d'arrêt maladie
par un arrêt de quinze jours ou plus et
l'augmentation des arrêts dillon
s'explique on le sait par le
vieillissement de la population des
fonctionnaires cette raison ne tient
donc pas mettre en cause les
commanditaires de étude qui révèle
l'impact positif du jour de carence est
un piètre argument quentin chiffres
embarrassants et publié vouloir casser
le thermomètre en quelque sorte ça ne
sert à rien plutôt que d'attaquer les
assureurs vous devriez au contraire
relancer la négociation sur la mutuelle
obligatoire des fonctionnaires qui
avaient été précédemment engagées face à
ce constat madame la ministre
qu'entendez vous faire allez vous
revenir sur la suppression la journée de
carence ou bien dans le cas contraire
allez-vous compensée aux collectivité
aux epito le manque à gagner de sa
suppression merci la parole à marylise
lebranchu
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup monsieur capo-canellas ce parce
qu'effectivement
cette étude a été très commentée c'est
une étude qui a été comme ans commandé
par des assureurs nous n'avons pas
encore de précisions vous non plus
d'ailleurs semble-t-il à la halle écoute
de votre question sur le fait que cette
société a déjà négocié 700 mille
contrats pour des agents du public
pourquoi parce qu'un certain nombre de
maires prenant acte de du jour de
carence il ya peu de temps de cela on
écoute et mutuelles et assureurs qui
leur en proposait de faire des contrats
collectifs de prévoyance certains
dépensent en entre entre 8 et 12 euros
par salarié et par mois pour schumi
nevers la prévoyance que
77 % des salariés du privé ont obtenu
tant mieux et quelques 50 % des salariés
du privé des toutes petites entreprises
et si on veut continuer en ce sens
effectivement de l'alignement on
pourrait aller jusqu'aux trois jours et
l'ensemble des maires de france
président des conseillers généraux
régionaux mais aussi la ministre et la
fonction publique que je suis
négocierait des contrats de prévoyance
et je comprends que même les mutuelles
que je respecte beaucoup où la société
sofaxis qui a eu quelques difficultés
avec les marchés publics mais qui a
effectivement beaucoup progressé depuis
sur cette notion de marché public de
prévoyance et de vente eu un formidable
marché ouvert
si nous gardons le jour de carence dans
la mesure où nos fonctionnaires monsieur
n'ont pas le droit à la complémentaire
santé dans la mesure où
23% de leurs collègues seulement du
privé ont encore le jour de carence ils
vont vous dire ils vont me dire ils vont
dire à tous leurs employeurs alors
allons-y jusqu'au bout de deux nous
donnez nous la complémentaire santé et
une assurance prévoyance fait la
différence du coup je me suis
capo-canellas entre les deux et
effectivement si vous voulez augmenter
la dépense publique gardons le jour de
carence négocions la complémentaire
santé parce que si vous voulez
rapprocher le public et le privé vous ne
vous pouvez pas ne le faire que sur le
jour de carence fallait jusqu'au bout il
ya eu un accord récent entre les
partenaires sociaux qui rend obligatoire
la complémentaire santé alors dans ce
cas retrouvons nous pour un vrai groupe
de travail pour savoir ce que va coûter
en dépense publique est la
complémentaire santé et la prévoyance de
couverture comme dans le privé des jours
de carence est pourquoi je trouve
dommageable que les sociétés
d'assurances utilise là pour obtenir ce
qu'elles veulent c'est un vaste marché
dommageable pour la dépense publique pas
dommage a pour elle je comprends
toujours qu'une entreprise cherche à
augmenter son chiffre d'affaires ya
aucun souci éthique de ma part mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi regarder de près
les chiffres parce que quand vous dites
les arènes on augmente parce que
les fonctionnaires vieillit c'est pas
tout à fait ça quand on s'arrête une
journée avec un paracétamol on
recommence le lendemain de l'annulation
de 40 merci on va voir le médecin et on
prend trois jours ou quatre jours
d'arrêt c'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle pour tout le monde merci la
parole et à claude jeannerot pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social mais elle implique
également monsieur le ministre chargé
des affaires européennes
l'emploi reste vous le savez la première
préoccupation des français
il est la priorité de l'action du
gouvernement
dans ce contexte où le niveau de chômage
reste élevé l'europe n'est pas toujours
perçue par nos compatriotes comme une
alliée de l'emploi on se rappelle projet
de directive bolkenstein dit du plombier
polonais qui risque est non seulement d'
aggraver le chômage mais aussi de faire
reculer le niveau économique et sociale
des salariés voilà qu'au cours des
dernières semaines une nouvelle
inquiétude surgissait sur le front
social
de quoi s'agit-il une directive
européenne de 1996 prévoit qu'une
entreprise peut détacher des salariés
dans un autre pays de l'union européenne
à condition d'appliquer les règles du
pays d'accueil en matière de salaires et
conditions de travail tout en versant
néanmoins les cotisations sociales dans
le pays d'origine alors que cette
réglementation avait précisément pour
objet d'organiser et d'encadrer les
conditions de la concurrence est là en
pratique était largement détournée
créant ainsi des situations de dumping
social inacceptable
pourquoi en effet embauché un
travailleur français quand par exemple
l'embauché d'un travailleur détachées
venant d'ailleurs permettent une
économie pouvant aller jusqu'à 30% comme
le démontre
le rapport réalisé par notre excellent
collègue éric bocquet au titre de la
commission européenne du sénat le 9
décembre dernier lors du conseil des
ministres de l'emploi européen vous avez
obtenu monsieur le ministre un accord
qui assure à l'évidence les contre-feux
nécessaire et porte pour l'avenir toutes
les garanties mais au-delà de ce nouvel
épisode nous pressentons tous ici que se
trouve posée l'avenir d'une europe
sociale capable de contribuer à créer du
progrès du développement et de l'emploi
pour tous à quand enfin le retour de
l'europe sociale merci monsieur le
ministre de nous éclairer sur les
perspectives concrètes issues de cet
accord merci ma parole à michel sapin
ministre du travail emploi formation
professionnelle
alors merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
la directive détachement elles datent de
1996 vous l'avez rappelé rapidement mais
à juste titre elle apporter un mieux à
l'époque elle encadrait ceux qui sinon
seraient restés la jungle et nous sommes
je pense les uns et les autres favorable
à la réglementation et à l'encadrement
plutôt qu'à la loi de la jungle mais
elle a donné lieu au cours de ces
dernières années parce que depuis 96
l'europe s'est élargi parce que
malheureusement depuis ces dernières
années la crise économique et ses
conséquences sur chacun nos territoires
a frappé elle a donné lieu non seulement
à une augmentation du nombre de ceux qui
sont détachés des tâches et ça veut dire
au fond être en situation d'intérim ce
sont des polonais des roumains des
bulgares des slovaques qui sautent en
intérim en france au service d'une
entreprise de droit français elle a
donné lieu dans qu'à une augmentation
considérable mais surtout à une
augmentation exponentielle des abus des
contournements au fond cette directive
est devenu le support d'une fraude
organisée qui permet de faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui certains salariés
surexploités ce qui en soi est déjà
considérablement condamnable face
bénéficier l'entreprise première celle
qui a au départ donné les ordres de prix
qui sont des prix totalement hors du
marché oui aujourd'hui c'est un support
à une concurrence déloyale un dumping
social
préjudiciable aux salariés eux mêmes aux
salariés français qui risque par là même
de perdre des emplois parce que des
marchés sont perdus par des entreprises
françaises qui elle-même trouve cette
situation scandaleuse l'europe a réagi
elle a réagi lundi dernier elle l'a fait
de manière majoritaire mais contre un
certain nombre de pays qui ont jusqu'au
bout maintenu une opposition parce que
l'on mette des réglementations
supplémentaires la grande-bretagne et la
hongrie par exemple ont maintenu leur
opposition à cette réglementation
supplémentaire réglementation nécessaire
au niveau européen si l'on veut lutter
contre ces fraudes organisées cette
cascade de sous traitants qui
progressivement faute opacité font
obstacle à la mise en cause de la
responsabilité du premier des
responsables qui est l'entreprise qui
donne des ordres cette cascade là on ne
peut lutter contre elle que s'il y
allait même ajouté dans l'ensemble des
pays européens c'est ce qui a été décidé
meilleures capacités de contrôle
meilleure capacité de punir il nous
faudra transcrire très rapidement et je
sais que des parlementaires vont prendre
des initiatives dans ce sens là ces
règles dans le droit français nous le
ferons même avant même que la directive
elle même soit adopté par le parlement
européen et il nous faudra et j'ai
commencé renforcer les contrôles sur le
territoire j'étais ce matin même sur un
chantier pour faire en sorte que la loi
française soit respecté que les droits
des travailleurs d'où qu'ils viennent
soit respectée et que la libre
concurrence non faussée soit respectée
merci la parole à hélène lipietz pour le
groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre l'économie monsieur le ministre
chargé des affaires européennes
à l'heure où la dépense publique et sous
pesé au trébuchet de la rigueur il est
scandaleux qu'un secteur
structurellement non rentables ne vivent
que de subventions je veux parler des
onze bateaux dédié à la pêche au chalut
renoue profonde une étude anglaise de
newco et une phonation rapporte qu'une
telle pêche engendre une perte de 153
euros par tonne de poissons pêchés en
effet il faut pêcher une tonne de
minimum de poisson pour obtenir une
tonne de poissons vendable à 200 euros
sur les étals d'une des dernières
enseigne à proposer empereur sabre noir
et autres ligue bleue et pour ce faire
chaque tonne van damme ou non aura
nécessité neuf cent vingt litres de
fioul la simple lecture d'un bilan
comptable d'un armateur en eau profonde
permet de découvrir que chaque tonnes
vendues génère une perte de 153 euros
malgré les subventions européennes et
celles du sur le fuel sortir les
chalutiers dédié à une telle pêche
génère un coût environnemental et
énergétique de 389 euros par tonne de
poissons pêchés au minimum et si au
moins cette pêche au chalut et est
pourvoyeuse d'emplois mais nécessite six
fois moins de pêcheurs que la pêche aux
palangres moins destructrice des
écosystèmes un armateur de
boulogne-sur-mer aperçu l'absurdité
économique de cette pêche ya mis fin est
devenu bénéficiaire
il semblerait que le plus gros des
armateurs s'y livrant et enfin pris
conscience de cette réalité et veulent
changer de mode de pêche certes sa
conversion ne date que d'avant-hier s'il
a gagné la bataille au parlement
européen il a en effet perdu la
confiance des consommateurs est
peut-être courtil donc derrière des
concurrents plus prompt à reconnaître
leurs erreurs
monsieur le ministre alors que 700 soit
dans douze mille pétitionnaires dénonce
le massacre des chaluts sur les fonds
marins et que des appels au boycott des
vendeurs d'une telle pêche font entendre
qu'en tant le gouvernement français
quand on le gouvernement français pour
aider à la conversion d'une dizaine de
bateaux à une pêche respectueuse de
l'environnement ce qui n'est pas le
souci du gouvernement je le crains et
moins coûteuse pour la france tant
financièrement que vous notre image de
marque je vous remercie
merci monsieur thierry documentaire
madame la sénatrice en fait la france
pêche d'une façon beaucoup plus encadré
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quelques années
l'état des stocks d'ailleurs péché par
les pêcheurs français s'améliore grâce à
un partenariat étroit entre
scientifiques et pêcheurs et il en
résulte une pêche plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et je crois qu'il faut
s'en féliciter mais il faut encore aller
plus loin et mieux encadrer la pêche
profonde afin de réduire encore son
impact sur l'environnement marin
car il est possible de concilier la
protection des écosystèmes marins
profonds vulnérables avec lé emplois
directs et indirects générés dans nos
ports par le secteur de la pêche c'est
d'ailleurs tout le sens du vote du
parlement européen qui vient de se
prononcer pour je cite l'encadrement
renforcé de la pêche profonde sans aller
jusqu'à son interdiction qui ne concerne
pas que onze navires mais plus de 700
suivant l'estimation de la commission
européenne les débats entre les états
membres au sein du conseil de l'union
européenne sont encore à venir puisque
je vous le rappelle que ce sujet relève
de la codécision entre le parlement
européen et le conseil la france sur ce
sujet s'est fixé un cap c'est le premier
ministre qui l'a rappelé lors de la
grande conférence environnementale la
france participe activement aux
discussions communautaires pour mieux
connaître et encadré la pêche en eau
profonde
la france défendra donc une approche
ambitieuse équilibré garantissant
l'équilibré en l'avion entre
l'environnemental le social et
l'économique concernant les aides je
vous rappelle que le régime européen est
très strict pour le domaine de la pêche
les aides directes pour le
fonctionnement des entreprises sont
interdites les aides à la construction
de la nièvre navires neufs sont elles
aussi interdites depuis 92 pour le reste
les aides autorisées sont celles qui
contribuent à améliorer l'exploitation
durable de nos ressources mais je vous
le dis il n'y a pas d' aides versées
spécifiquement à la pêche profonde
madame la sénatrice soyez assurés que
dans les négociations européennes la
france défendra cette approche à la fois
ambitieuse équilibré en n'oubliant pas
que c'est un secteur économique
notamment sur les zones maritimes et les
zones côtières de france
merci je passe la parole à présent à
marie hélène des esgaulx pour le groupe
ump
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues à ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre à nyon massivement augmenté les
impôts depuis juillet 2012 sans ligne
directrice vous avez fait naître un
sentiment d'incompréhension voire de
refus de l'impôt notre économie et nos
concitoyens souffrent aujourd'hui de ces
hausses d'impôts de ce matraquage fiscal
qui devait concerner que les riches qui
concerne tout le monde et
particulièrement les classes moyennes et
puis tout le monde souffrent de ces
mesures économiques contradictoires que
vous prenez alors elles annonçant sans
préparation une remise à plat de la
fiscalité vous ne fait qu'aggraver la
confusion et accroître les risques
d'effets très négatif sur notre économie
du fait de l'instabilité que vous créez
et que présage les acteurs économiques
monsieur le premier ministre dit il pas
tant d'avoir système fiscal qui soit
lisible cohérent
s'inscrivant dans la durée et coordonnée
à ceux de nos partenaires européens
parce que notre économie a besoin avant
tout de stabilité et de confiance
nous voudrions savoir monsieur le
premier ministre
quelle est votre méthode
quel est le calendrier de la réforme
quelle est la logique d'ensemble et pour
quels impôts parce que la fiscalité
locale parait-il serait-elle tel serait
traitée ultérieurement à 10 ans dit on
pourquoi la fiscalité aussi
environnemental est elle traitée à part
où on pas traiter du tout je pense
d'ailleurs à l'écotaxe par exemple alors
monsieur le problème istres nous
regrettons d'ores et déjà que vous ne
placier pas cette réforme au service de
la compétitivité de nos entreprises qui
sont seules sources de création
d'emplois durables nous regrettons qu'on
nous plaçait pas tout ça sous le signe
de la nécessaire réduction de la dépense
publique et puis moi je vous le dit la
seule réforme fiscale aujourd'hui qui
est possible c'est la réduction de nos
impôts
merci la parole à monsieur pierre
moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice marie-hélène des esgaulx je
vous remercie de votre question comme
toujours marqué de la bonhomie de la
lucidité et des signes d'encouragement
que vous nous avez prodigués du grand
équilibre de votre position qui me
touche toujours profondément je n'aurai
pas la cruauté de vous rappeler la
situation dans laquelle se trouvait la
france en 2012 mais je pourrais le faire
pendant cinq ans car c'est bien de ça
dont il s'agit il s'agit du redressement
des finances publiques du pays que vous
avez laissé avec un déficit qui était
supérieure à 5% du pib il s'agit du
désendettement progressif du pays car
vous avez accumulé 600 milliards de
dette publique en plus il s'agit du
redressement de la compétitivité du pays
car franchement quand vous évoquez ce
mot on se passe temps vous avez laissé
se dégrader cette compétitivité et je
n'aurai pas la cruauté de vous rappelez
vous même les mesures fiscales que vous
avez prises d'abord le paquet fiscal qui
a creusé les déficits puis ensuite les
hausses d'impôts plus de 1% par an en
2010 2011 est en effet 2012 et donc si
vous voulez parfois je me dis que plutôt
que de faire ce genre de péroraisons
vous devriez vous excuser auprès des
français alors
cela étant dit je veux vous expliquer ce
que le premier ministre entend faire car
c'est précisément une remise à plat de
notre système fiscal afin que celui ci
soit plus simple afin que celui ci soit
plus lisible afin qu'il y ait de la
stabilité qui en émergent et afin qu'il
y ait plus de justice dans ce système
fiscal et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons nous attaquer à la fois à la
fiscalité des entreprises avec la
volonté de préserver et d'améliorer la
compétitivité à la fiscalité des ménages
avec le souci de la simplifier et de la
rendre plus juste et au financement de
la protection sociale afin que celui ci
soit à la fois pérenniser et ils
demeurent appropriés par les partenaires
sociaux et qu'il crée de la justice
voilà ce que nous voulons faire et vous
le savez d'autant plus que le premier
ministre a souhaité recevoir les groupes
tous les groupes parlementaires et qu'il
a offert au groupe à tous les groupes de
s'associer à ce travail travail qui doit
trouver de premières concrétisations
dans le projet de loi finances pour 2015
mais qui en effet prendra plus de temps
que cela tant cette remise à plat est
une oeuvre de longue haleine et donc
n'essayez pas de faire peur aux français
au contraire nous voulons la une
fiscalité plus stable plus simple plus
juste plus lisible c'est cela que nous
voulons faire c'est le redressement
d'une situation que vous avez dégradée
et les français le savent
merci ce gilbert angers pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame george
pau-langevin ministre délégué chargé de
la réussite éducative
madame la ministre le gouvernement
depuis le début du quinquennat a mis la
priorité sur la refonte de l'éducation
en renforçant notamment les effectifs
enseignants dans les établissements
scolaires avec le recrutement prévu 2
1804 équivalents temps plein en 2014 en
portant haut un discours de respect sur
l'école le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a remporté un premier succès
puisqu'il y a eu plus d'inscrits au
concours de l'année 2013 que lorsque
ceux des années précédentes
cependant malgré les efforts consentis
je souhaiterais attirer votre attention
madame la ministre sur l'organisation
exceptionnelle nécessaires pour la
rentrée scolaire 2014 dans les collèges
de la seine saint denis pour faire face
aux nombreuses ouvertures
d'établissements dans le département lié
à une forte poussée démographique
en effet cinq collèges neufs seront
livrés à la rentrée 2014 avec chacun une
capacité d'accueil de 600 élèves ces
ouvertures nécessite la création de cinq
nouveaux gymnases de 5 cuisine centrale
et d'un internat liés au collège
international à noisy-le-grand le
département a adopté dès 2010 un plan
exceptionnel d'investissement de 723
millions d'euros en prévision de cette
forte augmentation des effectifs
scolaires déjà constaté dans les écoles
élémentaires mais il s'agit d'une
situation inédite puisque c'est la
première fois que dans un seul
département
l'éducation nationale doit se préparer à
l'ouverture concomitante de cinq
collèges neufs supplémentaires aussi
madame la ministre je vous demande de
vouloir bien m'indiquer comment
l'éducation nationale qu'on me préparer
très en amont la nomination de
l'ensemble des personnels d'éducation
qu'il s'agisse des principaux des cpe et
des professeurs merci madame georges
pour l'heure je veux ministre chargé de
la réussite éducative
monsieur le président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gilbert roger je souhaite
d'abord salué l'action des personnels de
l'éducation nationale qui s'engagent
chaque jour sur un territoire comme
celui de la seine saint denis où leur
tâche n'est pas toujours aisé j'ai eu
l'occasion de le constater récemment en
allant voir sur place ce qu'ils ont mis
en place avec la réforme des rythmes
éducatif et je dois dire que j'étais
très admirative de la manière dont les
s'implique au jour le jour pour donner à
ces enfants qui n'ont pas toutes les
chances les meilleurs moyens de réussir
grâce à cette réforme que nous avons
mises en place comme vous le savez
depuis que vincent peillon et moi même
nous sommes aux responsabilités nous
avons essayé de remédier à ce qui
s'était fait précédemment où
effectivement les agents et les élèves
en seine saint denis n'avait pas eu
l'impression d'être une priorité du
précédent gouvernement c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons fait un effort
significatif pour affecter de nouveaux
personnels sur l'académie de créteil ils
ont eu
405 postes supplémentaires pour
l'enseignement public du premier degré
430 pour le second degré ce qui a permis
d'essayer de régler cette question
lancinante des remplacements qui était
toujours insuffisant dans ce département
vous savez aussi que nous essayons de
faire en sorte que les dispositifs comme
plus de maîtres queux de classe ce qui
permet de scolariser les enfants petit
et bien tout cela soit davantage présent
en seine saint denis s'agissant de la
création de ces cinq collèges le
déroulement on devrait être à peu près
celui là d'abord saluons l'effort qui
est fait par le conseil général pour
permettre aux enfants de seine saint
denis d'avoir des établissements de
bonne qualité et je salue la
collaboration avec l'éducation nationale
qui se passe très bien je dois vous dire
que comme d'habitude nous avons donc
nommer chaque principal pour le collège
et ils ont une mission de suivi des
chantiers de supervision de la rentrée
2014 il y à aussi ensuite à nommer les
personnels enseignants ce qui se fera à
la suite et le nombre précis de ces
personnels sera arrêté à la mi-janvier
on tiendra compte évidemment des
partenariats en fait un travail sur la
sectorisation
de manière à faire en sorte que la
mixité soit 2 le plus possible respecter
sera aussi menée en liaison avec le
conseil général vous savez que l'étude
pisa nous a montré encore notre
responsabilité à l'égard des enfants
dans les quartiers populaires c'est en
travaillant ensemble que nous réussirons
à relever ces défis redoutables
merci la parole à claude domeizel pour
le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargée des personnes âgées
et de l'autonomie
être autonome est une des conditions
essentielles pour une vie équilibrée et
heureuse c'est vrai à tous les âges
salle est manifestement plus pour les
personnes âgées
le président de la république et le
premier ministre vous ont confié madame
la ministre une tâche immense
à l'effet le gouvernement a fixé dans
ses priorités
l'anticipation et la prévention de la
perte d'autonomie
oui pour reprendre une de vos
déclarations
il n'y a pas de fatalité
il est des situations sur lesquelles
nous pouvons et nous devons agir pour
préserver l'autonomie
au coeur de la prévention vous lancez
mona lisa
quelle belle acronyme frais et souriant
pour dénommer une mobilisation nationale
contre l'isolément social des ag
qui peut nier l'importance du lien
social dans la préservation de
l'autonomie c'est un sujet essentiel
partout dans les villes comme dans les
zones rurales
qu'il s'agisse de l'adaptation des
logements de la téléassistance des
actions collectives des ateliers des
ateliers associatifs qui porte sur
l'activité physique ou la nutrition
qu'il s'agisse aussi de l'aide à
domicile ce sont là des leviers pour la
préservation de l'autonomie modem la
ministre pouvez vous nous préciser selon
quel calendrier
et avec quels partenaires comptez vous
mener ses orientations au moment
d'engager cette concertation pouvez vous
nous indiquer quelle place comptez vous
accordez au rôle des caisses de retraite
dans le volet anticipation de votre
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation sur l'adaptation de la
société au vieillissement allez-vous
répondre au besoin de clarification de
leur place dans le champ de la
gérontologie je vous remercie
merci madame michèle delaunay ministre
chargée des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur de moselle en effet
vous l'avez souligné le volet
anticipation prévention du projet de loi
que nous allons vous présenter dans
l'année qui vient est tout à fait
essentiel c'est le moteur de la loi les
baby boomer qui avance en nombre dans le
champ de l'âge sont les premiers
accompagner massivement leurs parents
dans le très grand âge est aujourd'hui
ne veulent plus se laisser surprendre et
ils veulent anticiper et se préparer les
caisses de retraite ont d'ores et déjà
un rôle très important dans ce chan elle
accompagne les retraités elle les
informe elle les conseille et elle
développe celle culture de l'autonomie
au moment du passage à la retraite mais
aussi tout au long de l'avancée en âge
elles ont orienté leurs actions sociales
vers la préservation de l'autonomie en
faisant preuve de beaucoup d'innovation
et en engageant une coordination entre
les différents régimes elle développe
une vision large de cette prévention à
la fois individuellement sur les
comportements favorables et sur la
dénomination sociale elle finance vous
l'avez signalé des ateliers collectifs
elle contribue à l'amélioration des
logements avec l'anah elle contribue au
financement des logements foyers et des
résidences sociales
et enfin les accompagnons domicile et
gir 5 et 6 c'est à dire les personnes en
début de perte d'autonomie
quand celles ci connaissent les
difficultés sociales sans elle ces
personnes ne pouvaient ne pourrait pas
demeurer au domicile elles interviennent
également sur le lien social et vous
avez bien voulu signaler à l'attention
la mobilisation contre l'isolément des
âges est mon analyse à elle y participe
activement cette dimension est
aujourd'hui active sur le terrain dans
huit départements témoins et nous y
important de très grands espoirs de
reprise du lien social pour toutes les
générations
la place des caisses de retraite dans la
prévention est donc des joueurs c'est
déjà reconnu mais nous allons plus loin
nous engageons un dialogue avec les
partenaires sociaux puis en sont les
gestionnaires sur le renforcement de
l'accord convergence entre les régimes
dans les différentes actions menées et
elle ceci dans le prolongement ce
qu'elles sont d'ores et déjà amorcé il
s'agit de formaliser un socle commun de
l'action sociale garantissant un accès
égal à une politique publique nationale
de prévention de l'autonomie sur la base
de ces travaux nous devons améliorer la
coordination de ses politiques avec les
conseils généraux dont le chef de file à
sera conforme confirmé à l'occasion de
la loi et qui travailleront en
partenariat avec nos agences régionales
de santé merci madame la ministre
l'apparent le cas joël buillard pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur le ministre à la suite de votre
décret concernant les rythmes scolaires
l'inquiétude et la colère des élus des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves ne
s'apaise pas il est évident que proposer
une réforme de ce genre au niveau
national pouvant s'adapter à la fois à
une école isolée dans les zones rurales
et un groupe scolaire implanté dans une
grande ville est tout simplement
irréaliste
un cadre national ne peut donc se
concevoir sans dérogation tenant compte
des contraintes locales et bien entendu
de la spécificité des territoires ruraux
comme par exemple faire venir une heure
par jour une personne diplômée pour
encadrer les enfants à moins de mettre
en place une garderie ce qui ne
correspond pas à l'esprit du décret et
bien sûr sans oublier l'organisation et
le coût des transports
raison pour laquelle le groupe ump a
déposé à l'initiative de son président
une proposition de loi qui permet à
chaque commune de s'organiser comme elle
le souhaite afin de proposer aux enfants
et aux familles l'organisation la plus
favorable
il semblerait que votre réforme ne
permettent pas d'agir positivement sur
les rythmes biologiques de l'enfant
pourtant pourtant à la base du débat par
ailleurs si on en croit les expériences
passées les aménagements des rythmes
scolaires serait sans incidence sur le
résultat des élèves
comme il est facile de le constater
cette nouvelle organisation est
techniquement très difficilement
réalisable et financièrement
inacceptable d'autant plus que les
communes doit faire face sur trois ans à
une baisse de leurs dotations de
fonctionnement
à titre d'exemple pour ma commune cela
représente environ 10 points de
fiscalité compte tenu du ras-le-bol
fiscale cette nouvelle imposition n'est
pas envisageable
monsieur le ministre j'ai adressé une
lettre à tous les maires de mon
département en ce sens à savoir de
demander au gouvernement de renoncer à
ce décret ou de laisser aux communes le
libre choix de l'organisation du temps
scolaire et de garantir à celle ci la
compensation intégrale des charges
monsieur le ministre je me suis toujours
posé en défenseur de la ruralité et
aujourd'hui je continue à essayer
d'aider mes collègues maires qui se
débattent devant les multiples
difficultés rencontrées monsieur le
ministre écoutez des voix qui montent de
cette france profonde et donnez-leur
aujourd'hui la réponse qu'ils attendent
merci la parole à vincent peillon
ministre de l'éducation nationale
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur d'abord
il ya beaucoup d'éléments un dans votre
question le premier élément si vraiment
les rythmes scolaires n'avait aucune
incidence sur les résultats scolaires je
ne m'expliquerai pas que les groupes
parlementaires y compris ump et mon
collègue luc chatel ait fait une si
longue consultation qui arrivait à la
conclusion unanime comme l'académie de
médecine comme tous les pédopsychiatres
comme quoi il n'est pas légitime que la
france d'ailleurs vous savez bénéficier
vous dans votre jeunesse de cinq
matinées de classe soit le seul pays du
monde à n'avoir depuis 2008 que quatre
demi journées et cela a des conséquences
vous l'avez vu encore récemment sur le
niveau scolaire et donc vous ne pouvez
pas considérer à moins d'avoir
totalement changé d'avis mais ce serait
étonnant qu'en l'espace de deux ans ce
qui est établi par tout le monde ce qui
avait été porté par vous même lorsque
vous étiez aux responsabilités à savoir
de nouveaux rythmes scolaires soient
bons pour l'apprentissage maintenant sur
la question que vous soulevez c'est la
même il y a deux choses qu'il ne faut
pas confondre il y à notre constitution
il y a le code de l'éducation qui fait
que l'éducation est un service public
national et il revient à l'état de fixer
le temps scolaire et heureusement le
temps scolaire est fixé par l'état et de
ce point de vue là l'organisation du
temps scolaire ç'a toujours été le cas
d'ailleurs quand on est revenu à aux
quatre jours en 2008 il n'y a même pas
eu les consultations que j'ai organisé
dans l'autre sens il est décidé par
l'état par contre pour la première fois
et c'est sans doute ce qui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes dans
l'histoire des relations entre l'école
et les collectivités nous avons souhaité
et c'est ce que nous faisons pour le
passage aux 4 jours et demi demander
l'avis des maires les impliquer dans ce
qu'on appelle la coéducation pour
construire non seulement le temps
scolaire mais le temps périscolaire
mais sur ce temps périscolaire vous est
absolument libre aujourd'hui comme hier
il n'y a aucune contrainte le temps
scolaire c'est l'éducation nationale et
donc il y aura cours le mercredi matin
car c'est l'école qu'il assume ce qui
est après la classe et le temps scolaire
obligatoire revient aux collectivités
locales aujourd'hui comme hier et là
vous aurez les uns et les autres à
prendre vos responsabilités
il ya une nouveauté effectivement vous
avez raison il y à une nouveauté c'est
que pour la première fois l'état mais un
certain nombre de financements comme la
caisse d'allocations familiales pour
vous permettre de mieux le faire et je
serais intéressé à savoir ce que vous
faisiez avant l'association des maires
de france et le président de
l'association des maires ruraux l'a mis
en place chez lui et l'association des
maires de france qui est présidée par
l'ump a pu montrer que 80 % des mères
qui était passé en était satisfait et
que ça se passe mieux dans le rural
qu'ailleurs et donc de ce point de vue
là n'hésitez pas à consulter vos
collègues ils vous montreront comment
ils font pour le reste il ya peut-être
une certaine part de mauvaise volonté
peut-être pas finalement un intérêt pour
les élèves et les enfants à la hauteur
des exigences de l'autre pays mais vous
l'aviez prouver aussi quand vous étiez
aux responsabilités où vous n'avez rien
fait pour l'école de la république six
des pour la détruire progressivement
merci merci nous allons à feu chers
collègues nous en avons fini avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
vais suspendre la séance
sera reprise à 16h15 pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer
les sanctions prévues dans le cadre de
la mise en oeuvre de la loi du 5 juillet
2000 relative à l'accueil et l'habitat
et l'habitat des gens du voyage la
séance est suspendue
la séance est suspendue fin des
questions d'actualité mais évidemment
vous restez avec nous parce que nous on
refait la séance tout de suite
bienvenue à tous sur public sénat pour
on refait la séance le meilleur des
questions d'actualité et bien sûr
revenir